après un patrimoine à préserver que ce
soit une église un château il s'érige en
défenseur de bâtiments parfois mal en
point ce sont les bénévoles de
l'association urgence patrimoine on en
parle avec la présidente et fondatrice
de l'association alexandre à sapiac
bonjour à vous voilà vous êtes en duplex
de notre bureau d'auxerre alors c'est
une toute jeune association tous c'est
une toute jeune association urgence
patrimoine elle existe depuis 2014
pourquoi l'avoir créé alors j'ai eu
l'idée va pas révolutionnaire du tout de
créer cette association suite un petit
constat que j'avais fait sur serre en
visitant justement l'église saint-pierre
et en me disant qu'il y avait vraiment
une urgence absolue concernant la
restauration des édifices religieux en
particulier d'accord très bien alors
vous avez fait aussi peut-être un
constat citoyens finalement de
l'importance de s'intéresser à ce
patrimoine qui parfois se trouve dégradé
et je crois que vous avez réussi à avoir
autour de vous des bénévoles qui sont
maintenant présents dans toute la france
alors nous avons une cinquantaine de
bénévoles sur tout le territoire et nous
avons aussi ouvert tout de suite alors
pas par mégalomanie ou envies de
grandeur mais nous avons ouvert un peu
cette ce concept de de sauvegarde du
patrimoine on va dire par les citoyens
dans neuf pays d'europe
et maintenant en côte d'ivoire parce que
il est important d'aller chercher chez
les autres les bonnes idées et les
choses qui marchent
donc c'est bien d'avoir des échanges
comme ça avec avec d'autres pays et
d'autres d'autres personnes et d'autres
visions des choses alors des bénévoles
actifs puisque l'association s'engage
pour des réalisations concrètes c'est le
cas avec l'église saint-pierre d'auxerre
l'objectif mobiliser des fonds et des
consciences en garde ce reportage de
sébastien guay roux et yoann etienne une
façade rongés par l'humidité des blocs
de pierre à deux doigts de tomber
à première vue l'église saint-pierre
d'auxerre est bien mal en point
convaincue par l'action d'urgence
patrimoine une restauratrice est venue
sur place pour réaliser un premier état
des lieux les deux heures ce qui se
passe au niveau la gargouille voir la
pierre la lie à la pierre en
voilà la pierre d'alun complètement
celle là elle est morte
donc je pense que l'urgence allait
vraiment à 7 sur 7 gagnants enfin
vraiment sur cette partie là c'est
église et est en danger quand même
depuis de nombreuses années il ya
beaucoup de problème de charpente
beaucoup de problèmes d'étanchéité des
fuites au niveau de la toiture donc là
on arrive vraiment à l'extrême l'extrême
extrême limite pour la restauration
là il ya vraiment urgence à l'intérieur
l'usure du temps se fait aussi ressentir
les murs sont défraîchis l'étoile
détériorer ce qui inquiète le plus
l'état de certaines peintures murales
menacée de disparition
personnage je crois qu'il va faire son
âge à cheval on voit quasiment plus le
restaurateur qui interviendra il faudra
d'abord qu'il puisse éliminer les selles
ensuite il faudra poser des protections
en fait d'un tissé sur le décor pouvoir
tour fixé et ensuite seulement on pourra
faire une petite réintégration dans les
lacunes reboucher les lacunes et faire
une petite réintégration pictural et
c'est rattrapable
ça l'est encore mais c'est vrai que là
ça devient pour ses décors ci
particulièrement ça devient très urgent
objectifs de l'association urgence
patrimoine récolter au minimum quinze
mille euros pour s'attaquer dans un
premier temps à la rénovation de la
façade
une initiative saluée par le prêtre de
la paroisse on sait aussi à quel point
sur patrimoine et 1.1 point pour une
ville comme auxerre qui est un très
riche patrimoine religieux avec de
belles grandes églises la cathédrale
souvent on fait un peu de l'ombre aux
autres églises mais celle ci est aussi
très intéressante et évidemment on y est
très attaché et s'il peut y avoir des
initiatives locales qui peuvent être
prises par des particuliers au sein
d'associations je trouve que c'est une
excellente idée et pour permettre aux
auxerrois de participer à l' aventure
samuël ticket à 5 euros ont été mises en
vente
une vente qui s'effectuera jusqu'à ce
soir sur le marché de noël avant de se
poursuivre chez certains commerçants du
centre ville et sur internet alors
alexandra se faisait coup en êtes-vous
jeu de cette collecte là pour pour
l'église saint-pierre d'auxerre alors
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas encore
atteint notre objectif bien sûr mais
nous y croyons fort nous avons récolté
4238 euros précisément donc
notamment grâce à la participation de
d'un acteur économique local on va dire
qu'ils avaient fait une opération en
vendant des sapins dansant hypermarchés
et qui reversait 1 euro pour chaque
sapin achetez donc
d'ailleurs il y aura la remise du chèque
ce soir est donc avec on a obtenu cette
somme avec aussi la vente de deux petits
produits dérivés et nos fameux ticket
patrimoine alors donc ça ça continue
encore pour cette collecte est votre
action principale c'est d'abord d'être
dans l' alerte finalement de faire
prendre conscience de la nécessité de
protéger le patrimoine
bien sûr la sauvegarde du patrimoine ce
n'est pas uniquement la collecte de
fonds évidemment l'argent est le nerf de
la guerre il ya déjà des institutionnels
qui font ça fort bien donc nous on est
plus dans l'information et même on va
dire la prévention et parce qu'il est
important de mobiliser les gens et
d'ouvrir un petit peu les consciences à
tous ces problèmes de sauvegarde qui
sont de plus en plus important que ce
soit dans les grandes villes ou dans les
petites communes parce qu'il faut quand
même rappeler que ce patrimoine
il est quand même inestimable que les
touristes viennent en france pas pour
notre climat où notre amabilités
légendaire mais généralement pour
visiter nos trésors et qu'il est neutre
de notre devoir d'entretenir tout ça et
de se mobiliser pour ça alors vous lui
disiez le financement c'est un peu le
nerf de la guerre vous vous appuyez sur
quoi sur sur le mécénat c'est le
principe aussi du mécénat de compétences
des artisans qui interviennent
directement sur sur ces édifices comment
ça se passe oui alors le mécénat de
compétences c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis très très longtemps mais
qui n'est pas très répandu or il ya
beaucoup d'artisans qui sont prêts à
donner de leur temps parce qu'ils sont
passionnés par ce qu'ils aiment ce
patrimoine et donc ils restaurent où ils
interviennent gracieusement sur des
édifices et donc voilà ça permet de
diminuer un petit peu les charges soient
des propriétaires enfin des
propriétaires privés ou des communes et
ça c'est important de le développer en a
le cas là dans le reportage
l'âme de freitas qui est venu très
gentiment de touraine et qui d'ailleurs
fera la mise en sécurité des fresques
façon gracieuse donc ce qui représente à
peu près l'équivalent de 3000 euros en
donc évidemment sur les 5 millions
d'euros nécessaires à la restauration de
saint pierre sont des sommes qui sont
infimes mais sans les petits ruisseaux
qui font les grandes rivières
et puis c'est important d'alerter sur
sur ces problèmes là et donc l' alerte
elle peut être par rapport à un édifice
mais par rapport à une situation mais
nous sommes intervenus par bien compris
et alexandra se faisait il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire voilà pour
pour ce patrimoine et pour sa
valorisation merci à vous président de
l'association urgence patrimoine